it takes a while to really grab you is a
phrase we heard and said a lot in 2019
around video games many times in 2019 I
jump into a game after reading a glowing
review only to find myself two hours in
and wondering what on earth all the fuss
was about
because said game didn't grab me at all
and by said game I mean death stranding
and out of wilds and Fire Emblem three
houses and control and Jedi full and Oda
and Sakura shadows died twice and disco
Elysium because man did great videogames
really make us work for it last year
thankfully all that work paid off in
spades in so many instances across a
range of genres so here's a snapshot of
the most unusual and perplexing games
from that list that we had to learn to
love from last year though death
stranding was buoyed up by the
reputation of Hideo Kojima it wasn't
long after we got our first proper look
at the game that the phrases walking
simulator and FedEx simulator we're
getting thrown around online and not in
a good way
like many games from last year though
deaths trending seriously grows on you
underneath the melodramatic exposition
dump that makes up much of the main
story and the gameplay that's riddled
with shifting to the right and left
constantly so you don't fall down and
make digital Norman Reedus embarrass
himself there's so much heart and
serenity to be found if you dig a little
deeper it takes at least a dozen hours
to collect the tools that speed up your
long arduous journeys between delivery
points and even more for the game to
kick in to the more action-packed
episodes but there's beauty in the
slower moments and joy in bringing
people together and connecting both in
the story and incidentally with other
players who have left helpful signs and
structures behind death stranding wasn't
what anybody expected from Hideo
Kojima's next game but it's somehow
coalesced into something truly special
for those patient enough to hold down
our to win l2 than the first five or so
hours of the game
[Music]
last year a lot of people played their
first Fire Emblem game with the arrival
of three houses and as someone in that
group mustering the learning curve was a
real investment this is especially true
if you want to see the whole story which
would take you know fewer than full
playthroughs averaging 60 hours each or
if you're me 140 hours for a single
playthrough getting to that level of
commitment was trying at first the
opening hours treated newcomers to deep
RPG and turn-based combat systems
significant time management demands and
a cast of characters who didn't make the
best first impression I'm looking at you
Benedetta
fortunately the more hours you get into
the game the more nuance to the
characters get the more interesting the
story becomes and the more effecting
you'll find the overarching themes of
friendship and personal growth mastering
the gameplay elements and spending your
time wisely to see the evolution of as
many characters as possible is so well
worth the dozens of hours required to
get there so it's no big surprise that
so many people jumped in for another
go-around the fascinating fantasy world
in new game+
[Music]
game spots only 10 out of 10 game last
year disco Elysium easily joined the
ranks of games we had to grow to love if
deaths trending it's a walking simulator
then disco Elysium is a reading
simulator genuinely it's a whole ass
book
allegedly there are 1 million words to
read in the game and in the first couple
of hours when you're wading through
loads of exposition and complicated law
it can be difficult to see the light at
the end of the urban dystopia tunnel on
top of that disco Elysium is sort of an
RPG but one way you invest points in
things like rhetoric and visual calculus
it all makes sense when you get stuck in
but you do have to get stuck in for it
all to make sense the more time you
spend in the world the more you grow to
appreciate its eccentricities the
writing in Disco Elysium is unparalleled
it manages to be hilarious insightful
delightful and heartbreaking as a result
exploring its disheveled city replete
with characters trying to do their best
in
in circumstances and helping them in any
small way you can is more than worth the
effort
disco Elysium is challenging in a way
that it defies genre expectations in
almost every way but that's also what
makes it brilliant mobius digital's
whimsical out of wilds is the game that
almost didn't make it onto this list
despite it more than qualifying because
it took me so many tries to start
enjoying it the story is muddy about its
objectives and trusts you to make your
own way in the world with very little
guidance
it also trusts you to get the hang of
it's unwieldy ship which is more of a
lunar lander than a traditional
videogame spaceship I've given up on out
of wilds more times than I have fingers
but once I forget my frustrations enough
to wade back in I'm always rewarded with
some kind of morsel for my trouble the
pieces you add to the puzzle of the
game's story may be small and difficult
to uncover but putting together the
final picture is a satisfying journey
out of wilds has total faith in you to
adjust to it's curious controls retrace
your steps and not give up on it when
your progress milestones become few and
far between it's an admirable quality
that stands as a contrast to other games
drenched in glowing interactable x' and
objective markers and once the
frustration wears off and you can
achieve something on your own the
satisfaction of getting one step closer
to unraveling the story is unbeatable as
is the case in multiple great games from
2019 many of the things that make out a
wilds feel impenetrable are also the
things that make it feel unique and
special it and the other games I've
talked about stretched beyond what was
expected that there's on rizzo systems
and narrative structure though it meant
we endured a year of learning curves and
quote unquote getting to the good bit it
also meant we were treated with
exceptional games that rewarded our
patients with fascinating experiences
that shone in an entirely unexpected way
you